I'm just gonna come out and say it this
is a good show I have no idea why or how
but a show about hitmonkey of all things
is one of the better American adult
animated shows that's come out in years
it's no Invincible but I think it's
worthy enough to be included in
conversations about invincible and it
certainly Leaps and Bounds ahead of
Hulu's other failed train wreck of an
animated show modok chicken and yet just
like Modoc not a single damn soul is
talking about it online I think we ought
to change that take a look at this
eccentric series with me and let me tell
you why I think hitmonkey is worth
watching and definitely worth getting
another season
before we see how this extremely obscure
character managed to somehow have a
heartfelt intriguing and sincere action
comedy show before Deadpool
let's take it back to hit monkey's Roots
as a Marvel comic to see blood on earth
made that character even remotely worth
adapting I used to think you shouldn't
try to adapt a character unless they've
had a solo comic for at least 20 issues
this made me rethink that I got into
Deadpool with the Daniel way run which
is uh controversial and I remember not
being a fan of the back door pilot issue
where Spider-Man and Deadpool fight an
assassin monkey in a suit
something about it just felt lame and
gimmicky to me like the joke just wore
thin instantly yes it's a monkey and a
little suit and tie and he shoots people
that's hilarious then I never really
gave it much thought after that I knew
that he had his own Comics but I just
never really felt the need to pursue
them then I saw the trailer for this
show while paying like half attention to
it because I was like busy doing
something else I think and that painted
as this fast-paced joke filled action
schlockfest with Jason Sudeikis playing
the wisecracking human character and ah
what I saw of the trailer just
manifested is this really loud terrible
obnoxious version of the show in my head
I was picturing yet another animated
comic book show trying and failing to be
like Harley Quinn which I would have
probably hated and hating things makes
for more provocative video titles so I
thought I'd check it out I got a
business to run here kids leave me alone
check out my second Channel I post
videos on the second channel did you
hear the second Channel at first I did
my due diligence and read all of the hit
monkey solo comics
there's not a lot of them I was
expecting Daniel Way's worst but was
shocked to find out that it's some of
his best instead of just being a cringy
joke Fest it's a story about the guilt
of being a killer the lonely and endless
Path of Revenge and losing oneself to
violence but you know it's also about a
monkey shooting people too the story
starts with an assassin on death's door
after a double cross he wanders out into
the force of Japan and lays down in the
woods to die he awakens to find himself
being taken in by peaceful animals that
nurse him back to health with healing
herbs in a hot spring one of the tribe
of monkeys is aware of the kind of guy
he is and wants the assassin gone and
trying to spy on him he ends up learning
from the nameless hired killer and is
imparted some wisdom by the one he hates
soon after the Assassin's pursuers catch
up to him and shoot him dead as well as
the entire tribe leaving only one left
the lone monkey picks up the Assassin's
now ownerless weapon and begins a Path
of Revenge killing everyone that took
part the massacre of his people at this
point I was kind of digging it but I was
unsure how you can have a story about an
animal that can't speak running around
doing things that are pretty out of his
scope like tracking down names and
addresses and distinguishing who to kill
or operating Firearms but it's revealed
that the reason he's so above average
intelligence for his species is because
the spirit of the Assassin now lives in
his mind the dead assassin is still the
main character in a way and the monkey
is more of a vessel for him to take his
revenge from Beyond the Grave by guiding
him around and helping him know things
that he shouldn't be able to is just a
normal animal as a huge fan of the
Child's Play movies this caught my
interest I thought a monkey assassin in
a suit shooting people was too stupid
but then you add in the factor of him
being partially possessed by the spirit
of a dead human assassin and that pushes
it so far over the edge of stupid that
Loops back around and now I can actually
take it seriously again
I figured this was the first thing the
show would cut or change and they'd have
the Assassin just be alive throughout
the whole story and be a silly annoying
dick through the whole thing so the
audience has had at least one kind of
normalish thing to attach to because
admittedly a buddy Adventure between a
ghost and a monkey is a hard one to
accept even though conceptually it's
it's [ __ ] awesome and in spite of
this weirdness it ends up being kind of
a dour and sad book like yeah the
premise is silly but the execution still
lingers on all these heavy themes and
the violence is played so straight it's
never reveling in being badass to the
extreme
eventually the monkey kills everyone
that he wanted revenge on but Witnesses
super assassin Bullseye kill an innocent
child and that just leads him to wanting
even more revenge against Bullseye and
whoever else he comes across that's a
hired killer it's this vicious cycle of
never finding peace on this path and
being trapped killing and killing
forever with no end in sight
he's like The Punisher but a monkey and
targeting assassins globally instead of
just organized crimes Stateside and as I
was reading this I just kept remembering
the loud obnoxious trailer for the show
and how the human assassin was a
wisecracking goofball and the action was
so silly and I I couldn't picture any of
these moments happening in the show the
Assassins saying about picking up a
weapon and anger the Assassin dying in
the snow and his vengeful Spirit forcing
this innocent creature down a path of
Destruction That Never Ends
these were the moments that changed my
mind about the character being dumb and
worthless and I didn't think the Hulu
series would have the sense to recreate
any of that because admittedly I've
become very jaded toward Hollywood
adaptations of comics especially
animated ones after Modoc so
yeah
Hulu released a boring heartless trashy
animated show about a dumb unlikable
animal with no charisma
and they also release hitmonkey help but
then I watched the show in the Assassin
now named Bryce isn't really meant to be
the haha funny character
he's wisecracking and doesn't take
anything seriously but it's just a
shield to hide that he's This Bitter
broken man that struggles with the guilt
of who he is and what he's done killing
is not easy
not just point shoot and watch the bad
guy go bye-bye it's watch you go bye-bye
because every time you kill someone a
little bit of you dies too
right in the first episode he pulls off
this assassination and then there's this
long quiet sequence of him just
lamenting his crime no jokes no
punctuating the scene with a Joss Whedon
style wisecrack well that just happened
just this quiet reflective moment of
sadness
Bryce's character actually reminds me a
lot of how Daniel way wrote Deadpool on
his better days
he's wisecracking and being silly but
he's not really played for comedy the
tone of the overall story is still
relatively serious he's just one
character using humor to cope with being
a monster
he's the only real comic relief in a
show that's otherwise played very
earnestly despite the weirdness of its
premise and I respect the hell out of
that and in the first episode alone they
Faithfully bring all these moments that
I like from the book To Life almost seen
for scene
just with a little more context and
giving Bryce more of a personality
I wouldn't do that if I were you
pick up one of these in anger
and you'll never put it down
that right there is what just won me
over and look at that the whole show is
about him being a ghost in the monkey's
head
I guess I just didn't notice that part
in the trailer somehow my eyes are
busted
I'm a stupid Zoomer who's always looking
at his phone and pays 20 attention to
everything but a hundred percent to
nothing so anyway they actually made me
care about this nft reject
Hulu's hit monkey is full of
hard-hitting moments that don't always
try to make you laugh they try to attach
you to the plight of these characters
the protagonists are damaged people who
are struggling to find their place in a
violent and strange world
and along the way they do manage to have
some fun and they do it with some style
monkey and Bryce's Dynamic is more
fleshed out in the series and they're
both fully formed characters that play
off each other well despite the fact
that one of them can't interact with the
world around him and the other can't
speak to anyone except Bryce and other
animals
I really like this story and all the
additions that the comic didn't have are
welcomed and fit well we actually get to
see the assassination that Bryce did to
ignite the story and cause his own death
and it creates this mystery plot to
figure out who is the real criminal that
hired him he kills a politician that's
running to become the Prime Minister of
Japan and it throws the lives of
everyone around that candidate into
chaos but it also causes corruption and
crime to spike because that candidate
was the only thing left standing in
their way from Total Control now Bryce's
spirit in his animal companion have to
kill their way up the underworld's chain
of command to find out who is behind it
all and stop the corruption from
completely tearing apart Tokyo this
expansion of the story allows for a lot
more interesting stuff with the new
original human characters like Akiko the
idealistic young speechwriter for her
uncle Shinji who tried to run for office
after their friend and running mate was
killed for standing up to the criminals
and corporations hitmonkey's trail of
Revenge also attracts the attention of
Ito and Haruka two Japanese police
officers one's a veteran and the other's
rookie so they both approach all of this
chaos with very different mentalities
and techniques all of these additions to
the cast really give the story more meat
and fill the running time with more
substance than just if they adapted the
four issues paneled panel I think this
version of the story May ultimately be
better for that choice to add these
extra characters
the series is of course also set in some
variation of the Marvel universe so
naturally there are some cameos and
references here and there to that world
that thankfully aren't intrusive or
forced the show still feels very much
self-contained and unreliant on these
references and they're only there to
service what the show is trying to
accomplish on its own really they only
reach out to Marvel content that feels
tonally appropriate to mingle with the
show so no cringy mention of the
Avengers or MCU favorites are thrown in
being set in the Marvel Universe also
allows for a few cool original
characters that casually have
superpowers because that's just how it
is to be in the Marvel Universe a ton of
people get super powers from one thing
or another you can get powers from being
bit by radioactive Jackrabbit in this
world that happened once meaning monkey
can have some interesting battles here
and there with characters that have
their own unique gimmicks costumes and
powers to break up the usual armed
Yakuza gun battles oh oh oh dear Jesus
oh God no there's a Modoc reference I
thought the crossover was scrap please
don't date this with that unfunny
big-headed duel I love the political
crime drama thing this show is going for
in between all the anti-hero actiony
elements it's really well written in
having this series set exclusively in
Japan was an interesting choice pretty
much every Marvel story is set in the
United States more specifically New York
city so seeing a part of the world
outside of that was a fresh idea that
helped this stand out they also have a
nearly all Asian voice cast outside of
Jason Sudeikis and that helps the
setting feel more authentic and really
allows for some va's I haven't heard
before to shine in bigger roles here
this was a story I wasn't expecting to
be so fascinated by but I loved every
second of it and I want to see what
happens next
and damn it if this show doesn't
actually have some really cool visuals
to drive the story home
I truly love the look of this show no
monkey business here
yes the animation is obviously very
budgeted it's closer to something like
Archer than Harley Quinn are invincible
but I think the show's art design and
Direction work overtime to distract from
that these backgrounds are gorgeously
rendered the camera work and
cinematography is surprisingly Dynamic
and full of life that really amps up the
excitement or The Melancholy when
necessary and the animation spikes up
into being pretty smooth just when it
needs to be they really did the absolute
best with the limitations they had to
work with and as such I think the show's
visual style ends up being really unique
and cool I didn't feel like it looked
stiff or boring when it easily could
have with this basic tweening art style
even the fight scenes managed to be
pretty kinetic and Powerful though the
animation quality sometimes lacks in
other places when you could tell they
were saving up for the really important
scenes you're sick
sometimes cutting a corner is clever
instead of lazy because it lets the
animators Focus their time and attention
on the really good stuff
don't you worry sir you can always trust
me
hitmonkey is a well-crafted show that
could have easily just been some
obnoxious cash grab pulling from
whatever random Marvel IP hasn't been
adapted yet to further milk the current
hype for Marvel stuff but it's not that
somehow I feel like people who worked on
this show were all putting in their a
game for a project that no one is
talking about or excited for so I want
to personally say hey
I noticed I appreciated the [ __ ] out of
all that effort I love the show and I
would absolutely watch more of it if you
got a subscription to Hulu go take a
gander and tell me if I'm totally crazy
or if this show is way better than it
had any right to be
[Music]
[Music]
foreign